scientists discovered a new protein  known as pikachurin  and pikachurin is an extracellular  matrix protein highly enriched in retina  it was first described in 2008 by a  japanese scientist known as shigeru satu  and it is named after pikachu the  pokemon because of its lightning  properties  pikachurin is a protein which is  enriched in retina and it is important  in phototransduction  this is the structure of retina where  you can see photoreceptor cells bipolar  cells and retinal ganglionic cells  electric impulses get transferred from  the photoreceptor cell to the bipolar  cell and ultimately goes to the retinal  ganglionic cell from there it goes to  the brain  pikachurin acts in the synapse between  photoreceptor and bipolar cell it is  actually a district like an interacting  protein which has essential roles in  phototransduction that's one minute you  in next video